Why we Sing Auld Lang Syne on New Year’s
Eve
This tradition is mostly thanks to Guy Lombardo
and the Royal Canadian Band.
While their work is largely unknown to those
born in the last few decades, the band has
sold over 300 million records to date.
Guy Lombardo himself has three stars on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame, and he was once the
“Dick Clark” of New Years before Clark
and his “New Year’s Rockin’ Eve,”
attempting to appeal to younger audiences,
started supplanting “Mr. New Year’s Eve,”
Guy Lombardo.
It was in 1929 that Guy Lombardo and his band
took the stage at the Roosevelt Hotel in New
York City on New Year’s Eve.
Their performance that night was being broadcast
on the radio, before midnight Eastern-time
on CBS, then after on NBC radio.
At midnight, as a transition between the broadcasts,
the song they chose to play was an old Scottish
folk song Lombardo had first heard from Scottish
immigrants in Ontario.
The song was Auld Lang Syne.
Previous to this, there are several documented
instances of others singing this song on New
Year’s Eve, going all the way back to the
mid-nineteenth century, but it wasn’t anywhere
close to the staple it would soon be after
Lombardo’s performance.
The next year, and every year thereafter,
all the way to 1976, with Lombardo dying at
the age of 75 in 1977, they played it at midnight
on New Year’s Eve at first broadcast out
on the radio and later on TV.
Thanks to “Mr. New Year’s Eve” and his
band, it’s still tradition
to this day.